i saw that video and i was like yo
this is this is a high level of
disrespect here
obviously yeah um song bang you know
what i'm saying but
when you saw it like what was your
initial reaction when you saw that thing
uh i really wanna
i ain't gonna call i really went mad i
was just like on some more
just because i do the same thing you
know i'm saying i
like you know i said i've been making
this songs and like [ __ ] like that so
i know how they be feeling but i went i
i really went like
too much press i was more of mad like uh
like certain people like that was saying
in that part with my dad brother's name
no man i really weren't mad at the song
itself i don't know
you were just mad at that part yo my
brother's name my dad by the name of it
like it's a good song
so yeah i mean i think that the other
thing that's probably gonna be weird is
the fact that like that part you're
talking about
is also a part that's like became a meme
yeah
so like you might see somebody replace
you know i've seen some basketball ones
you know what i'm saying where like a
basketball player will pop you know
but but but it's that's that's got to be
kind of
like that [ __ ] it's when something goes
viral like that it's almost like [ __ ]
that's what it is and then you know
those people got families and like you
said those
you know that's your fam you know what
i'm saying definitely um